sprechen kann man noch allerdings spiele
geht nicht mehr
alexandra nun us-musiker fußballfan gar
sportler
der test beim sportwissenschaftler zeigt
erstaunliches doch dazu später der
alltag des aus uruguay stammenden
hornisten er beginnt um sechs sportler
schlafen da meist noch seine sport
kleider kein zufall
bald schon beginnt er zu schwitzen
es ist sehr anstrengend
ich vergleiche es mit einer sportstunde
dauern
ein ding zu machen von 6 uhr nachmittags
bis um mitternacht und ein fußballspiel
nie 600 fußball und bei uns es ist
wirklich so lange zusammen mit fisch
sportlich und kondition konzentration so
kommt zu üben das mobiliar verrät es
krafttraining für den ganzen körper dazu
heißt auch für die lippen
seine wichtigste muskelgruppe und
gleichzeitig die schwächste des menschen
aber nun ja es geht auch laufen wie es
sich für einen musiker gehört mit dem
metronom als schrittmacher
sein lungenvolumen erstaunliche
sechseinhalb liter so viel wie ein
radprofi zwei mal pro woche geht er noch
ins karatetraining sport und musik
beschäftigen ihn bis zehn stunden
täglich mehr als jeder spitzensportler
trainiert so hat er auch mit 53 keine
körperlichen beschwerden
im gegensatz zu vielen musikerkollegen
open air kino in bern das
sinfonieorchester basel vor der live
vertonung des films das parfum der
solohornist ist nervös steht unter
besonderem druck
ein falscher ton jeder hielt ihn es ist
wie sieg oder niederlage im sport der
leistungsdruck für musiker wie sportler
enorm musiker bekämpfen ihn oft mit
beruhigungsmitteln die beta blockern
nunez verzichtet bewusst darauf sie
treiben spitzensport ohne eine haltung
die offenbar in sport wie musik nicht
bei allen geht die vorstellung hat
begonnen
zweieinhalb stunden dauert sie länger
als ein marathon ohne pause
das braucht ausdauer
wie fit ist er denn der musiker wir sind
in einem swiss olympic medical center
beim sportwissenschaftler der auch viele
spitzensportler testet fest motiviert
bist du zum um alles zu geben heute beim
test 1 ist auch eigentlich überhaupt
nicht ich finde es doof perfekt gemacht
ok
alle drei minuten rollt das band nun
schneller dazwischen nimmt der
sportwissenschaftler blut dass er
analysiert nuñez soll rennen bis zur
erschöpfung
nach 15 minuten ist schluss
das resultat kann man eigentlich kann
man nur gratulieren man sieht dass du
dass du viel trainiert dass du immobilie
was machst das du regelmässig arbeitest
ich würde das gern bei einem volkslauf
würde er locker in der vorderen
ranglistenhälfte der 50-jährigen landen
er ist also fitter als mancher sportler
zurück zu den grausigen bilder des
parfüms so grauslich wie unterdessen das
wetter
nach sportlichen zweieinhalb stunden der
ablass der wettkampf pardon
das konzert ist vorbei das orchester
besteigt wie ein fußballteam den bus
doch bei allen gemeinsamkeiten zwischen
sport und musik núñez der als junger von
einer fußballkarriere geträumt hat weiß
doch noch einen gewichtigen unterschied
die größte fußball
wir müssen den leuten diese perfektion
von den cds werden sie manchmal lieber
fußballer aus musik und dann könnt ihr
ein elfmeter